وداعا جوليا اول فيلم سوداني يشارك ويعرض
في مهرجان كان السينمائي
لحظات فرح عاشها مخرج الفيلم وطاقم العمل
مع ادراجه في المهرجان لكن الفرحه امتزجت
بالحزن والالم على الاوضاع التي يعيشها
السودان
[موسيقى]
في ريلي بالد اي ووتر ريد كارد بيبر راني
[تصفيق]
الفيلم يسلط الضوء على تاثير انفصال جنوب
السودان عن السودان عام 2011
ويستقيم واقع الاحداث شغف السودانيين في
التعايش السلمي
الموضوع مؤثر فيه
صوتك حلو يا
منى
تدور احداث الفيلم في الخرطوم قبيل انفصال
الجنوب حيث تتسبب امراه من الشمال تعيش مع
زوجها بمقتل رجل جنوبي ثم تقوم بتعيين
زوجته جوليا التي تبحث عنه كمساعده في
منزلها سعيا لتطهير نفسها من الاحساس
بالذنب مي المهندس العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات